[موسيقى]
شكرا اسرائيل لان افعالك لم تكذب خبرا
سمعناه لقد اخبرونا انك تنقضي العهود فلم
تصدقي عهدا منذ مؤتمر مدريد وما قبل مدريد
ببعيد قالوا انك تشعلين الفتن بين الشعوب
حتى اصبحت عنوانا لكل فتنه قالوا ان جنودك
لا يقاتلون الا من وراء تحصينات فاضت على
الوصف الا من تحت طائرات تدمر كل ما يخيف
عسكرك المرعوب قالوا انك تاكلين اموال
الناس بغير حق وجيشك عفش بيوت اليهود قبل
بيوت المسلمين قالوا انك تحر فين الحقائق
فتخطط افكك في اقبيه مستشفيات غزه قالوا
انك تقتلين الاطفال والنساء فكان عطشك
دفينا
لدمائهم قالوا انك تفسدين في الارض وهل
افسد من سرقه الاوطان وتدميرها وحرق اهلها
وهم احياء شكرا اسرائيل لقد عززت ثقتنا
بثقافتنا وجعلتنا مطمئنين الى اننا على
الحق المبين تكتب فتاه
فلسطينيه الى
العناوين مبيد الاطفال نتنياهو يريد اعاده
صياغه دين الاسلام حاخام صفد لجنود
الاحتلال ضعوا الاخلاق جانبا ودمروا
غزه وزير الدفاع الامريكي لا يستبعد هزيمه
استراتيجيه لاسرائيل
الموساد يضع مشع وهنيه والعاروري واخرين
على قائمه
الاغتيالات انتشار حالات اسهال حاد في
صفوف الجنود
الاسرائيليين في
غزه نساء اجنبيات يشهرن اسلامهن تاثرا
بصبر المسلمين في
غزه رئيس البرازيل يسال عن اشعارات التحسس
عند جو باي
ماكرون لا يرى هدف القضاء على حماس قابلا
للتحقيق الطفله ايميلي تعلمت على اكرام
الضيف ومشاركه
[موسيقى]
الطعام مرحبا بنيامين نتنياهو الذي وقف في
الحرب يستدعي لجيشه نصوصا دينيه تشرع لهم
اباده الفلسطينيين حين قال يجب ان تتذكروا
ما فعله عماليق بكم كما يقول لنا كتابنا
المقدس وعماليق قوم ذكروا في سفر صموئيل
الاول فكان النص المقدس بصيغه الامر اذهب
وحارب عماليق اقضي عليهم قضاء تاما هم وكل
ما لهم لا تصفق عليهم اقتل جميع الرجال
والنساء والاطفال
والرضع الاطفال والرضع لمن لا يسمع واقتل
ثيران وغنمهم وجمالهم وحميره وحاربهم حتى
يفنوا هذا النتنياهو الذي يحث القتله على
اباده الاطفال بنصوص دينيه معروفه يقدسها
ويتبناها على الملا العربي قبل الامريكي
والاوروبي وقبل الاسرائيلي بالطبع ويسير
فيها خلف كتيبه من الحاخامات
الموقرين من الجيش وعموم الاسرائيليين
ولاحظ الازهر الشريف ان هؤلاء الحاخامات
يحسدون لعمليات الاباده هذا النتنياهو
يريد اعاده صياغه دين الاسلام لنزع التطرف
عنه يقول بكلمات لا تستطيع ان تغطي دماء
الاطفال التي تصل الى اخمص
قدميه
ar some
it
takis
as as
ja يريد نتنياهو ومن يحركه تعميم هذا
المشهد مثلا على العالم الاسلامي
الله الله الله الله الله الله يزعج
نتنياهو ومن يقف خلفه وامامه مشهد
المقاومين الفلسطينيين الساجدين على تراب
وطنهم ولا تزعجهم صور جنودهم المتدينين
يقيمون طقوسهم على اشلاء بيوت مساكين
دمروها واحتلوها
يتباهون بجرائمهم ويستعرضون مسروقاتهم
امام الكاميرات في غزه ويسخرون من معاناه
اهلها والاهم عندهم نصب الشمعدان هناك
والاحتفال بعيد الحانوكا
اليهودي
لمت
والد وزير التراث الاسرائيلي الذي لا يرى
باسا برمي غزه بقنبله نوويه هو حاخام صفد
البارز جدا شموئيل
الياهو الذي سبق ان اعتبر زلزال تركيا
وسوريا الاخير عقابا من الله وصيته
الراهنه للجنود ضعوا الاخلاق جانبا ودمروا
غزه لان التوراه بحسب زعمه لا تقبل منك ان
تقوم بنصف عملك وبينما دعا الحاخام الياه
الجيش الاسرائيلي الى وضع الاخلاق جانبا
بحسب تعبيره وتدمير غزه حذر خبراء من
تاثير تصريحاته وتبعاتها على ثقه
الاسرائيليين
بجيشهم القاعده هي ان لا تقوم بنصف عملك
هذا ما تقوله التوراه اي عليك ان تعرف كيف
تسقطهم حتى النهايه سندمر لهم غزه تصريحات
الحاخام شموئيل الياهو الذي يجتمع مع
الجنود ويحاضر فيهم اثناء الحرب اثارت
عاصفه في اروقه الجيش الاسرائيلي وللتذكير
فان الحاخام شموئيل هو والد وزير التراث
عمي خاي الياهو الذي لم يستبعد القاء
قنبله نوويه على قطاع غزه رئيس حزب
اسرائيل بيتنا وزير الدفاع الاسبق اكدور
ليبرمان
يحسمها لا يوجد ابرياء في غزه اما رئيس
الحكومه ومجرم الحرب السابق ايهود اولمرت
بحسب التصنيف الدولي فهو ينبه نتنياهو الى
ان الوقت المتاح للعمليات في غزه قصير جدا
يعني ابيدو بسرعه لاني لا اعتقد ان هذه
الحكومه تعرف ما الذي تواجهه وما يجب فعله
والجميع يدرك ان الحديث بشان امتلاكنا
الوقت اشهرا او حتى السنه المقبله
كلام فارغ ليس له اساس في الواقع الوقت
الذي لدينا قصير جدا انها حرب اسرائيليه
على الاطفال في غزه بشهاده دوليه مختومه
من المتحدث باسم
اليونيسف
ماذا تريد اسرائيل بعد حشر معظم الغزيين
في جنوب القطاع ثم استقبالها لهم هناك
بحمام دم لا يقل وحشيه عن مجازرها في
الشمال كشفت تقارير اعلاميه اسرائيليه عن
وجود خطه مشتركه امريكيه اسرائيليه لتوطين
سكان غزه في اربع دول عربيه وهي مصر
والعراق واليمن وتركيا وتتضمن الخطه تقديم
مساعدات اقتصاديه امريكيه لتلك الدول
مقابل قبولها استقبال عدد محدد من
اللاجئين الفلسطينيين حيث ستستقبل مصر
مليون لاجئ وتركيا نصف مليون فيما سيذهب
150 ال لاجئ لكل من العراق واليمن وزير
الدفاع الامريكي لويد اوستن لا يستبعد
هزيمه استراتيجيه اسرائيل مع قتلها المزيد
من
المدنيين امريكا الحنون منزعجه من قتل
اسرائيل اطفالا باسلحه امريكيه ارسلتها
امريكا لاسرائيل لتصطاد
العصافير لا يمكن الانتصار في حرب المدن
الا من خلال حمايه المدنيين لانه في هذا
النوع من الحروب يمثل السكان المدنيون
نقطه الارتكاز واذا دفعتهم الى احضان
العدو فانك ت تبدل النصره التكتيكيه
بهزيمه استراتيجيه في نفس الوقت ينتشر في
الولايات المتحده مرض يمنع اعين المسؤولين
من رؤيه الدماء
فوزارة بدايه الحرب على غزه فضلا عن نكبه
صحفيين باسرهم التي تم استهدافها في
بيوتها هذه المدينه ماهوله جدا بالسكان
وتحوي اعدادا كبيره من النازحين عائلتي
انا زوجي
واطفالي يتواجدون في هذه المدينه السكنيه
ولا ادري حتى اللحظه شيء
عنهم نتمنى نتمن لك ولعائلتك ربا السلامه
للجميع ينون ميجال صحفي مقرب من نتنياهو
يضع القلم والكاميرا جانبا ويشارك الجنود
بقصف احد بيوت غزه وباعتراف
وما زال البحث جاريا عن مدني في اسرائيل
يعلقون
الصحفيه الفلسطينيه الكنديه يارا جمال
تطرد من قناه سي تي في الاخباريه لانها
قالت يمكن ان يعيش اليهود في دوله فلسطين
ولكن بدون الفكر الصهيوني الذي لا يؤمن
اصلا بوجود دوله
فلسطين
تحه لام الغربي بعدما وضعت اسرائيل سمعه
بعضه في الحضيض بتبنيه رواياتها
الهوليوديه صحيفه لوموند الفرنسيه نسفت
الروايه الاسرائيليه بشان مستشفى الشفاء
كما شكك فريق التحقيق بوجود اسلحه
بالمستشفى وفي فيديو اخر تبين ان ما زعمت
اسرائيل انه مدخل نفق بمستشفى الشفاء يقع
في شمال بيت حانون على ع كيلومترات الا
الرئيس الامريكي لم يتب بعد عن تبني
الروايات الاسرائيليه وجديدها واخرها ان
جنود المقاومه مارسوا الاغتصاب الجنسي
فبناها بسرعه بايدن كالعاده قبل ان يتحقق
اسرائيل تعبث ايضا خارج الحدود مع دلال
غربي لها غير محدود المساد يسرب اوامر
تلقاها باغتيال قاده حماس خارج فلسطين
وقال المسؤولون ان الاستخبارات
الاسرائيليه تعمل بامر من رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي على تطوير خطه لملاحقه قاده
حماس لا سما في قطر ولبنان وتركيا طوفان
الاقصى عرضه تلفزيون الاقصى في غزه العام
الماضي بمسلسل درامي يحاكي شيئا منه لكن
المساد ضربت عليه الغفله فاليوم نغزوهم
ولا يغزونا
احنا حنتحر على موقع كوسوفي بمجرد السيطره
عليه حنبدا نتحرك على معسكر رعيم اللي
بصير اما معركه كبيره راح تقضي على دوله
اسرائيل بالكامل او بروفا بروفا لمعركه
التحرير طب مش هيك خطر على المجاهدين
حيكونوا سيطروا على المكان ونسخ قاعده
البيانات السريه بالكامل وصار بايديهم
مجموعه كبيره من الاسر مجموعه غيره
المقاتلين تخلي دوله اسرائيل تطلب مساعده
من امريكا مهزله مهزله افي فيس ضابط
اسرائيلي متقاعد يؤكد هروب ضباط كبار من
غلاف غزه في السابع من اكتوبر بعض الضباط
الجبناء في ذلك اليوم الفظيع هربوا وتركوا
الجنود والجندي وراءهم وهم ضباط رعوا
المستوى جدا تصرفوا بجبن لن افصل اكثر كي
لا امس بالمعنويات يكفي انه نشر يوم امس
بان هناك ثمانيه جنود اصيبوا بنيران صديقه
واصيب ايضا مواطنون وهذه المعلومات هي
معلومات موثوقه وجاءت عن ضابطين برتبه
ملازم اول ونقيب تحدثت الصحف الاسرائيليه
عن انتشار مرض معوي مثير للقلق في صفوف
جيش الاحتلال يتسبب باسهال حاد ومتكرر كل
20 دقيقه وقد تم اجلاء من قطاع غزه لتلقي
العلاج سيقولون انه تسمم لكن امهاتهم
يدعون لهم الان ربنا سهل امعاء ابنائنا
ليهربوا من غزه مع الهاربين يقول
[تصفيق]
بهي
[موسيقى]
اصمدي يا غزه العزه القاصف بهون رح ناخذ
بيتار الشهداء البطل
بمليون لك علينا ه العهد نحنا ما
بخون انت يا ارض السلام يا بلد
الزيتون يا بلد الزيتون طفله فلسطينيه تحت
الانقاض تناشد المسعفين بتركها وانقاذ
عائلتها اولا وقبلها انتم مين يا الما كنا
اخواتي
وامي
وح طب عايشين يا الم اللي معك اه عايشين
هنا ايش يا الما سعد ابن وابويا واخواتي
وستي وكل حياتي بع انا اخر واحده بديش انا
اك اولى ساعدتوني اخر واحده و اقول لك
خليني اساعد اول واحده عشان اساعدكم قديش
عمرك انت عمره 12 هنا هذ ام هنا وامي هنا
تطبع اخر قبله على جبين امها الشهيده
وتعدها بالصبر
والصمود قولي يما قول الحمد لله يما قولي
لا حول ولا قوه الا بالله الله اكبر كبيرا
والحمد لله كثيرا يا رب لك الحمد كما
ينبغي لجلال وجهك وعظيم سلطانك يا الله
والله صامدين والله واخر نفس من تحت
الركام من تحت الارض طالعين فيذه ان
تنصروا الله ينصركم جيش محمد هذا جيش محمد
لا يهزم ما لا يقهر وربنا موجود مش حطلع
من بيتي وفلسطين حتضل فلسطين عهد لا ينقضه
مسن حولوا داره الى انقاض راح شهداء في
هذا البيت ثلاث ثلاث شهداء الولدين الكبار
والبنت لام انت ايش قاعد بتسوي هنا على
الركان والله انا قاعد جان من كل ه الدنيا
لانه لا ان دار نسكن فيها ولا ان حا
وحكايتنا يعني مشتته لا غطا ولا شي ولا
وين كتوه وينه فبقق عند على حجارات داري
افضلي حتى لو كانوا اليهود يقتلوني انا
كمان فيان شاء الله باذن الله فلسطين
حضرها فلسطين
وحنظل نكافح
حتى اخر نقطه في دم الانسان لفلسطين صدقنا
الله فصدق يقولها بعد استشهاد ابنائه
احفاده فاي ايمان يسكن قلبه يا رب يا رب
يا رب يا رب صدقنا الله الله
صدقنا الله صدقنا الله
صدقنا ولله الحمد والمنه يا الله لك الحمد
كما ينبغي لجلال وجهك العظيم سلطانك ناشطه
امريكيه كانت تشك بوجود الله تعالى تقول
انها رات الدلائل على وجود الله في صبر
المسلمين في غزه على
قو الشر بحسب
وصفها في استراليا وفي الولايات المتحده
وبعد مشاهد الاحتساب عند الله التي يسجلها
اهل غزه
الصابرون نساء وفنانات ومؤثرات يعتنقن
الاسلام وينطق بالشهادتين
ويترحم على
[موسيقى]
الشهداء
pal
people into
is all dev the are through and to see
call out
to مقاطع تنشر لاال يقراون القران فوق
الانقاض كلا ان الانسان ليطغى ان راه
استغنى ان الى ربك الرجعه ايها القاتل
ايها المتخاذل ايها الساكت وقال ركبوا
فيها بسم الله مجريها
ومرساها
ان ربي لغفور
رحيم
ك ان ال
[موسيقى]
انسان لا
يطس
الى
ربك
[موسيقى]
رجعا الله
الله اكبر
[موسيقى]
الله اكبر مسجد غزه يفتتح في شمال سوريا
على نفقه فلسطينيين وسوريين هي صوره
حقيقيه لمسجد غزه بقريه ملهم الحمد لله رب
العالمين اللي قدرنا انه نعمر وننفذ هذا
المسجد طبعا بتبرع كريم من مجموعه من
المتبرعين منهم واهمهم
[موسيقى]
نعمر مساجد نعمر قرى سكنيه للناس
المحتاجه الرئيس البرازيلي لويس ايناسيو
لولا سيلفا لا يستطيع ان يفهم كيف ان
الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن لا اشعارات
التحسس اء دماء الاطفال
والنساء لو كان رئيس البرازيل يفهم اللغه
العربيه ماذا كان سيقول للسيد احمد ابو
الغيط وما
يمثل
بعد وقفه غير مسبوقه لسفراء فرنسا في دول
عربيه حيث وقعوا على مذكره جماعيه تطالب
باريس بالعوده الى توازنها وتعديل موقفها
المؤيد للعدوان على غزه استغرب الرئيس
الفرنسي امانويل ماكرون فكره القضاء على
حركه المقاومه الاسلاميه حماس ودعا الى
حمايه المدنيين في
غزه qu'est-ce que c'est est-ce que
quelqu'un pense que c'est possible c'est
la guerre dur il n pas dec durable pour
isra dans la rion
si هل وصل متاخرا جدا نعم لكن افضل من ان
لا يصل ابدا وذلك بفضل سفرائه الذين فكروا
هذه المره بطريقه
عاقله الاعلامي الفرنسي ويلسون فاس يوجه
رساله تضامن مع صحفي غزه لانكم فلسطينيون
وعرب ومسلمون يهاجم من يفتقرون
لخي que vous palestinien arab musul on
dit de vous vous des propagandist peut
mme des terroristes les gens qui n
aucune doute de la vre mais nous on vous
voit tel que vous des journalistes qui
font un travail inestimable dans des
circonstances impossibles
[تصفيق]
النظم على الطريقه الامريكيه في العراق
اسرائيل توزعوا على جنودها في غزه اوراق
لعب بصور قاده حماس واغلى ورقه ليحيى
السنوار اللي لعب نتنياهو بالثلاث ورقات
يقولون هذه بطاقه لاعب بصور وجوه قياده
حماس صنعتها اسرائيل ووزعتها على جنودها
فقد تمت الاشاره الى سنوار وشقيقه محمد
بورقه الجوكر هذه الخطوه لم تكن اختراعا
اسرائيليا فقد فعل الجيش الامريكي شيئا
مماثلا بعد غزو العراق عام 2003 حينما قام
بتوزيع اوراق لاعب على جنوده تحمل صور
شخصيات مطلوبه من نظام الرئيس الراحل صدام
حسين الطفله الاسرائيليه ايميلي وبعد فك
احتجازها في غزه
بمبادلتهم الضيف ومشاركه الطعام تقول
شقيقتها الكبرى ت م
[موسيقى]
وما لو اسر بنيامين نتنياهو الذي استفت
محاكمته بتهم الفد وجهت اليه لكان قد تعلم
وزوجته ساره على غسل ثيابهما وهما الذان
اعتادا على حمل غسيله ما الوسخ الى البيت
الابيض اثناء الزيارات الرسميه لتنظيفها
مجانا في غسالات كبار
[موسيقى]
الضيوف ختاما سلام عليك يا طفل غزه على
عينيك المفتوحتين على مشهد موت ان سبقتك
اليه اصوات
عنتريه سلام على لسانك الذي يتمتم بكلمات
وجع ابلغ من بيانات الامه
العربيه سلام على راسك الذي اتسع لاحلام
شتى ولم يتسع له بيته الصغير ليحيا حياه
عاديه سلام على قلبك الطيب ما كان يحتاج
كل هذه الاسلحه
الغربيه سلام على روحك الحره ترفرف في جنه
ابديه وحمدا لله وشكرا ان جعل اخره لهذه
الدنيه يثاب فيها الصابرون نعيما ويصلى
فيها المجرمون جحيما
ابديه الى اللقاء اطفال من تحت الردم ش
نشرح لها ما تعرف غير المحبه بس وين
اهلها يا ربي من عل السماء نزلنا حلها
ملينا من هذا الظلم جيناك الباب يا رب
الارباب لاج على الباب في يا رب الارباب
لاجئ على الباب كل الخلق يا خالقي باعونا
بتراب كل الخلق يا خالق بعونا
بتراب كل الخلق يا خالق باعونا
[موسيقى]
بتراب